some Democrats are saying the president
needs to federalize uh the Texas
National Guard let me throw a diversity
hire Karen Jean Pierre uh explaining
what the
uh explaining what the administration
might do Homeland Security Department
has asked for access to this park that
is now currently in dispute it doesn't
seem like they've gotten it uh they now
are allowed to cut down razor wire some
Democrats are saying the president needs
to federalize uh the Texas National
Guard so look something that could
happen I mean look I'll say this uh you
know the border patrol agents are now as
you said allowed to cut through the wire
because of what the Supreme Court laid
out it's it's unfortunate that we had to
go there it's unfortunate that there is
a governor in Texas governor Abbott who
has politicized this issue of what's
happening on the border and it's not
making people's lives safer it's
actually making it harder for law
enforcement at the at the border to do
their job and so we have been very clear
we want to make sure we get something
done at the border that's why we've been
having these conversation with with
Senate Republicans and democrats for the
past several weeks to come up with a
bipartisan agreement to deal with the
border and look if that the governor is
not interested in that Governor Abbott
is not interested in that he wants to
politicize an issue and he's not helping
communities he actually isn't and he's
actually putting border patrol agents In
Harm's Way by doing what he's doing I'm
not going to speak to any actions that
the president might take may not take
but we have been very clear on this
conomy um I mean everything she said
there is a confusion or an outright lie
or backwards but Sarah to try to give
the devil his due here to me it seems
that what Democrats think or at least
what this Administration thinks is that
border Patrol's job is to process
immigrants not to protect the Border
like that's actually what they believe
and if we acknowledge that then we can
start fighting with them properly does
that does that seem fair to you yeah
that is what pisses me off so much every
single time I hear these people Trot out
and repeat these lines that border
patrol needs more more resources not to
protect you and me not to protect actual
Americans just to process these unvetted
strangers and allow them into the
Interiors of our country it is
absolutely reprehensible I'm old enough
to remember a time when Border Patrol
was actually there to enforce the law
and keep these people out instead
they're just glorified processors where
they give them a little note and say hey
promise that you'll really super pinky
promise that you're going to be out of
court in the year 2032 and we'll just
really really hope that you show up wink
wink I mean it's disgusting and you have
these people I just heard a story the
other day of a woman I believe her name
was Tammy Nobles whose daughter was
autistic developmentally disabled who
was killed strangled to death by an ms3
gang member because border patrol and
the Department of Homeland Security is
not doing their damn job and I'm so
tired of hearing this cuz here's what
you'll hear from the sorry I'm on a rant
here's what you hear from the left guys
here's what you hear from the left okay
we need more even from the the NYC mayor
Eric Adams and and all of these Democrat
lawmakers who are Sanctuary cities until
all the brown people show up at their
doors step and they're like wait a
second we didn't plan for this to happen
here's what they say they don't say
close the border they say we need more
Federal resources thrown our way to
house these people we're going to get to
a point where there's geographically no
place else for them to go and these
people are so disgusting that they think
that throwing more of our taxpayer money
is going to solve the problem when
really it's just going to I mean it's
disastrous it's going to be disastrous
for decades with these people we have to
have someone in office who is willing to
say we have to start mass deportations
now I believe that's what we call Sarah
Gonzalez unfiltered debuting on Monday
malice what do you think the argument is
like if you were in the white house
right now and there's that elderly man
with dementia there and the diversity
higher and the and mayorcas with the
eyebrows and all the people if they're
sitting in there what do you think
they're saying to each other right now
do they think they're doing the right
thing well they know that this is
something that benefits the Democratic
party both in the short term and long
term uh they're not incorrect at all uh
you know obviously anyone who has a kid
on American soil that kid is
automatically a citizen so that you know
this you know I think we all remember in
2016 when some horrific corporate
journalist yelled at president Trump for
using the term anchor baby and he goes
no no no I'm going to use the term
anchor baby uh but you know I I'm saying
this is an immigrant um this is
something that if a nation does not when
we came over we had that a family
sponsor us to be responsible like
meaning they were accountable now
there's just absolute no accountability
cuz we don't know who half these people
are they're throwing out their ID cards
you know intentionally I'm all for
humanitarianism to a point but if you're
not able to sift between who's coming
over because they're fleeing some sort
of genocide or who's coming over because
they're a a military age male who just
wants to have an easy life and and and
not going to be able to integrate into
society which is going to lead to very
harmful consequences this is a serious
concern so as to your question what
they're doing in the White House I I
don't think they know what to do because
this is the first time I think for a
very long time when a republican
Governor any Governor pretty much has
stood up to the federal government to
such an extent I'm delighted by this so
they're I'm sure their phones are
ringing off the hook uh here in Austin
with Governor Abbott and the Beautiful
Thing is both House and Senate are a tie
so you don't have the space to any make
any kind of big moves like the Congress
is effectively crippled uh so this is
really a wonderful time for things to
escalate in Direction it needs to go